olá a todos
essa regra é só uma grande mas parece
que toda a minha vida é assim caminhou
prestarem saúde também maior e mais
pequenas e praticar porque a gente vai
tocar para muita gente é minha grande
paixão é a música e saxofone
atualmente está mais vocacionada para o
ensino médio quanto em uma cena é aquela
paixão inicial
eu na china uma família de músicos ao
que parece
reza a história que a primeira parte da
minha casa eu tô aí contigo você sai
mexida foi no piano e me pôs irmãozinhos
em cannes em cima do piano
acho que assim obrigava yumiko ichi
fukuda
acho que dispõe a pagar tô então eu
achei minha casa pois essa mexida
salvaram e no final e após as visitas no
piano e m mas já era cantora lírica o
meu avô materna era somente uma banda
filarmônica banda filarmônica de como
toda a gente sabe são instituições com
muito peso na nossa sociedade a
portuguesa existem muitas são as
conservatórias do povo é e então muito
centro da música tinha três anos quando
fui da música é muito cedo também
percebi que era isso que eu queria fazer
era negro paixão continua em seu posto
para computar o conservatório leiria
fui para lisboa ao fim da universidade
até que fui atrás do meu grande sonho
que era e para frança está uma coisa
patagônia e fui lá fui eu e tal
vamos juntos salvar essas coisas todas a
frança deu a oportunidade de trabalhar
com grande mérito do saxofone e conhecer
suas fantásticas deve pessoas todas as
nossas inovados havia se estiverem a ver
hoje há pessoas no japão e joabe a
espanha tem amigos estou aqui graças a
deus
e nessa altura dizia ser a escola é
imensa
nós chegávamos a escola muito cedo era
um dos primeiros casa eo nas coisas
só que sua forma e é um dos últimos a
sair então imaginei isso todos os dias
todos os dias inclusive a fim de semana
em que nós nos cansamos quase nada isto
para dizer que essa altura fiquei doente
e teve uma grande
nos dois braços e percebi que ela tinha
desistido da que é um grande sonho que
eu tinha só que eu começamos teimosa
ricci no sony é uma grande paixão
resolvi que não irá desistir estava
completamente fora de questão e por essa
razão disse eu vou me curar e ponto
final e assim foi
é entretanto a nesse interregno em que
eu não podia tocar saxofone é descobrir
um saxofonista que o roedor tu é que
está a escola os meus colegas na região
chinesa já havia ter passado aqui esta
coisa é que o rio e toda a grécia
descobriu rodriguinho deve ter senhor é
impressionou me imensa descobrir quando
ela fazer as pesquisas têm mais tempo
não podia estar tanto o estado quanto à
recuperação e descobrir o que me
impressionou sobre o time do horto é que
além de ter a mesma profissão que os
partilhar a minha paixão pelo saxofone
pela música e ela era uma pessoa
completamente a fora do normal fora do
seu tempo e ela foi uma pessoa que o
wando a sua paixão pelo site só fará a
vantagem a ele que seu imenso fez uma
série de discos no início do ano de 2011
é contemporânea do charlie chaplin e do
ep o domingo 17 à noite apresentou a
gente conhece foi um gênio considerado
um dos maiores gênios do século 20 ou r
de nenhum dos meus mas que também é
contemporâneo de si e tem um gênio
comprava alguma maneira
rudolf fazer os riscos existem mas
sucesso porque condenáveis disse que já
que utilizava uma coisa que nunca antes
conhecidos vai ter efeito no saxofone
ria o saque software que o viram
agora é que o site o pantaneiro saxofone
as chaves da sala
não perguntei é só um a mais
olá eu sou feminista e então eu vi eu
vendo é que os milionários torna-se mais
cuidado mundial por isso o saxofone
provoca uma verdadeira febre do saxofone
que vai terá inclusivamente ano por
questões na história do jazz
estamos a falar do início do século 21
já a estação e desenvolvendo
vai ter também influencia as pessoas
chegavam e nós queremos estar sofrendo
mais com o santos
vejam a importância que isso o tempo
está a nível mundial é como tarzan é
difícil então ela é lançar a certa
altura o saxofone foi como nos sacs ou
fã é eo saxofone um é um tremendo
sucesso é coisa mais intensamente o que
nós podemos pensar em uma pessoa que
toca saxofone possa ter alguns tipos de
sucesso ao enriquecer mas é aí que eu
penso como de outra nos ensina muita
coisa ruim deve ter um virtuoso do
saxofone e eu vou a paixão dela às
últimas consequências
nesse sentido moura acredita então essas
tais riscos para assegurar melhor e eu
com o paixão dele vai influenciar muito
longe e mudou a história do instrumento
é um instrumento que o sábado foi
inventado no final do século 19
ah e para os mais atentos à questão
necessária esta semana fez 200 anos do
nascimento do saxo inventor do saxofone
soprano na quinta-feira ainda que
algumas pessoas que se acabe samsung que
estiveram presentes no evento é então o
rio e do future na paixão dela e ela
nisso ok eu sou assim
eu tenho estudo com saxofone tem este
longo da competição porque compunha as
próprias músicas
vou isso mostrou ao mundo e eu penso que
coisa que eu quero deixar aqui hoje
principal e ver e eu quero que ele tenha
um hoje é é que o importante é essa
história não é o saxofone
embora pra mim seja portanto nessa
história é que nós demos mais foi nada
daquilo que nós mais gostamos e e e
mostrar isso ao mundo não vale a pena
ter medo de mostrar aquilo aos tops e
que nós fazemos melhor é trocar saxofone
então muita gente mostra do cazaquistão
fora se a surfar como máquina mara teve
aqui um ano passado
muitos vêm se fazer rimas maravilhosas
como o brt vi aqui hoje seja se a
escrever se algo for
tentei que a gente o passo para o mundo
porque ao passarmos isso pro mundo isso
vai ter uma influência tremenda isso que
faço não dá pra frente é isso que faz o
mundo melhorará e eu tenho certeza que
toda a gente tem um alvo único em si há
algum talento não tem que ter a ver com
vida artística de maneira nenhuma e ao
porem se trancado por fora não sabemos
qual vai ser o impacto mas podem voar
primeiro evento a vida todos nós como se
nós pensarmos nas principais invenções
da história é alguém que ama e vai até
às vezes considerado louco como rudolph
escala foi ao episódio fazer um disco
com saxofone havia empatado banco a
equipa ainda teve tanta mas vendeu menos
riscos jurídicos milan e eu penso que é
mesmo essa é a grande lição para nós
temos hoje em dia sobretudo a vocês que
são jovens que estão agora a escolher
uma profissão que estão na escola alguns
acham que irão que são mais velhos que
uma profissão que já tem alguns sonhos
o mundo necessita que o que somos únicos
a fazer é que você está é importante não
interessa estar em copiar alguém porque
não interessa aqui você já tá aí já é
importante mostrar ao mundo
muito obrigado